hey guys how's it going so right now I
am waiting at the airport to pick up
Jenna
in Pittsburgh which is kind of weird
because usually it's her coming to pick
me up in Pittsburgh but now she lives in
California and I was here before her so
we're getting ready for Thanksgiving
festivities I'm also preparing myself
mentally and vlog mentally for vlogmas
which is vlog every day in December so
I'm going to kind of try to do it on my
main channel I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to do it but I'm going to try my
my absolute hardest to make it work so
it'll be a combination of vlogs a
combination of my normal videos so in
between the normal videos will be vlogs
we'll see what happens
[Music]
Jennifer's thing she said this is so
great you picking me up sure it's good
coffee though oh my gosh before we get
rolling but I was rollin man I love
cheese have you seen these one time we
don't need to eat them cuz I'm so undone
hungry I got two of them
no yeah really like my blood sugar like
look at me like I'm like shake it why
got your coffee so that's not gonna help
at all no we asked her to join you all
should we do it closer to home or do
anyone here do gonna get food what do
you want to do dig boehm okay there we
go please move like I need this to
happen before we oh we're missing the
shot
well no cuz it's getting lower I mean
it's just a bike yeah but it was moving
by itself
nobody was driving the bike oh you so
zoomed feels that is cuz Bo was licking
it it is time to shop for Thanksgiving
dinner
but our Thanksgiving dinner is gonna be
a little separate because my
Thanksgiving dinner is gonna be how I
will cook for Thanksgiving okay we need
potatoes cranberries something maybe
some stuffing in something turkey some
stuffing in turkeys that does not look
like Thanksgiving maybe if you find a
cornucopia
that's a yam
I need regular potatoes to make mashed
potatoes do you know how to make mashed
potatoes blender oh my god there's like
so many potatoes
which ones do I get
not those can I get a Google search can
you search well just get one
I don't know which one to get
I feel like I'm going to do this because
I don't want to take the skin off she's
got a point
and if I do this will be brown
well no thanks
all players
yes cranberry sauce is something that I
think is something that you have at
Thanksgiving so I'm going to get some
cranberries
blend them up could I get a quick google
cranberry sauce i jus wanna see does
anything else I should add to it
two cups granulated sugar water one
cinnamon stick teaspoon okay that's too
big wow that's
chicas
do you think this is a pound it's not
bad a packraft okay that's gonna like my
question is there oh wait yeah I think
this is where everybody's at there's got
to be there's gotta be something happen
why isn't there just like a section for
like Thanksgiving
it's like real hard
to Turkey about four or five six hours
shut up No
we're gonna need to find another
solution because this is just seens
Thanksgiving dinner we're gonna make a
quick simple oh my gosh look at this I
could just get mashed potatoes pizza
turkey breasts look
this is going to be delicious turkey or
regular turkey going to calorie this is
in like a little bag yeah we got a we
got to watch our calories so this is
going to be one meal and it's going to
be just for me
I don't think anybody else shaved white
turkey oh that's a lot we already have
breasts oh and we have a little packet I
feel like we need gravy and some
stuffing with real broth all right hmm
so we need two more things we're going
to need so this is that you chose to put
the turkey in the stuffing but like a
I'm not going to do that I don't take
them on no but we need frozen some
frozen veggies and a jar of turkey gravy
where's a pair of ninja just grab just
grab the turkey broth it's gonna have to
do I don't know I don't wanna hurt
activist Pete really oh no it's just I
don't like it here
[Music]